if we are simply working in our own
little silos we miss the opportunity to
do interdisciplinary work and to do
really deep innovation work
[Music]
jennifer kenny thank you for being on my
show 20 minute leaders how are you
very well delighted to join you thank
you thank you where are you calling from
right now
i'm calling from marin county just north
of san francisco
oh wonderful beautiful beautiful area
jennifer i'm extremely excited for this
talk because there's going to be a lot
we're going to have to talk about
because you have
so much experience in the realm of
innovation and leadership
and and balanced leadership which we'll
get to as well
and and really the the role of it of the
role of innovation within
within organizations um i'd love to
start out with
your journey and who is jennifer and and
how did you get to where you are today
um so i'm actually a geotechnical
engineer by training so i started off
doing geology and chemistry um
but that is the essence of systems
thinking uh so anyone out there who's a
geologist
and they know they're one of the best
systems thinkers on the planet because
we understand the planetary nature of
systems thinking
um and then i um ended up doing work
uh in technology um because i wasn't
uh as a woman wasn't allowed to do the
work i wanted to do in geology
and so i joined um anderson consulting
in london
and that began my career in technology
they effectively gave me the equivalent
of a computer science degree which was
fantastic
um and i have been in technology and
information technology since
uh uh most recently as a cio down at
stanford research institute
and now more recently very very focused
on the whole research and innovation
space
so research and innovation space what
does that even mean what is that what
does that even entail
yeah so what that entails is working
directly with people who are
doing um robotics autonomous driving
artificial intelligence blockchain all
of that kind of work
um in uh in the re in their research
capacity
so really helping teams of people uh do
their optimal to build uh emerging the
emerging technologies are gonna be
super exciting for the future and we're
beginning to see some of that already
so what what is what is your expertise
in that realm so you mentioned a bunch
of different
industries and they're very very you
know different from each other and each
require different expertise
what do you see yourself as the added
value that you bring when you're when
you're examining these different
companies and you're working with these
leaderships
yeah so my specific expertise is in what
i refer to as human innovation
which is the ability yeah so i ended up
doing this work primarily because
working in information technology i
always saw that there was a huge missing
in people's ability to be able to do
really really good design work and i
don't mean
product design work i mean how it is
that we actually co-invent together
and one of the enormously powerful
capabilities for innovation teams today
is the individual and collective human
beings ability to be able to co-invent
because as our technologies become
progressively more complex
if we are simply working in our own
little silos we miss the opportunity to
do interdisciplinary work and to do
really deep innovation work
um so i focused um through working with
some of the
really serendipitously working with some
of the world's sort of thought leaders
and when i was younger
um in understanding human cognition and
human language and how that
influenced our ability to be able to
innovate and co-invent
um and i have brought that now um
through years of practice and discipline
into the research and innovation space
and so i work with teams to
increase their innovation capacity okay
so jennifer
i'm running a team let's say i'm
starting a company and i have different
silos and we're working on a variety of
different projects what are things as a
leader that i can harness
in the realms of innovation how do i
foster innovation
instead of stifling it yeah so one of
the things
is um really beginning to look at a
different
framework for understanding how it is
that we manage and lead
traditionally all of our management and
leadership
um paradigms and principles have
originated from command and control
where we are the leader and we are
supposed to be all knowing
and those of us who've been around long
enough know that that's complete fallacy
um and so it's really how do you
begin to enhance your capability to
have the brilliance of your team emerge
and that you become a cultivator of
emergence rather than you become
uh someone who's telling other people
what to do and so it's beginning so i
would end up working with you to help
you build that
up build yourself as that observer
increase your capabilities in that space
and be able to really improve the
autonomy and mastery of your team as a
result of doing that
right so i guess the balancing question
the complementary question to that
is what common pitfalls do you see among
amongst leaders so
you know leaders are all around us
whether they're c-level executives at
companies or their
or their tech team leaders or their
teachers in a school
that are their own leaders in in many
ways what do you see as what do you see
are some common pitfalls that
that people do that they're just harming
both themselves and the team
yeah i think one of the saddest ones is
believing that you need to have all the
answers and a lot of leaders
really think that that's their role um i
think one of the
fundamental differences between leaders
who amplify
others and who cultivate others are
people who
are really clear on what it is they know
and what they don't know
and who are open to continuous learning
from all
from people all around them and i think
if you look at some of the more
brilliant leaders today
they will openly acknowledge they hire
people who are smart smarter than
them and they deeply listen to those
people uh
so a lot of it is our belief that we
should
have the answers and then our belief
that um
listening is is actually more about
hearing than it is really about attuning
yourself to someone else's brilliance
which is kind of what you're doing with
this interview process
right you're tuning into what's what's
unique and brilliant about these people
i'm talking to
well i'm definitely trying and i think
that one of the one of the fun things
that i get to do is i get to
learn you know really interesting things
from every person's you know inside so
you've had so many years of experience
in this field
and and i have the privilege of now
staying here and sort of interrogating
you to find those nuggets
that that could be meaningful on my
journey but that difference between
hearing and tuning in talk to me about
that a little
uh so what we tend to do is we
tend to communicate with each other from
the perspective of transferring
information
um rather than really taking the time to
um be deeply listen
be empathetic and really understand what
matters to other people what other
people are
passionate about what they care about
and how they see and interpret the world
and we people can be trained how to do
that
and in doing that what they do is they
begin to
um build build the bridges and build the
opportunities that allow them to be able
to co-invent
where the capabilities of two people or
three people or four people come
together
and produce something that neither of
them could produce independently
so that the magnifying the the
amplifying and magnifying capability
of um people learning how to build this
skill set and this competency is pretty
significant
[Music]
so as we continue on on this journey of
you know research with innovation what
is left to uncover do you think because
it sounds to me like you know the the
way that humans are and the the way you
would do teamwork
there's been so much research done on
that in the past i guess century is
there much more to innovate when it
comes to human innovation
like there's tons more so we're doing a
super interesting project
with a client at the moment where we're
looking at how do we
um really deeply understand the
decision-making process of some of the
lead innovators what it is that they're
seeing how they're interpreting the
world
how they're making those decisions how
much of it is
um based deeply on their experience and
how much of it is
replicable by other people so we're
literally building
an ontology of research innovation
and looking at how we do that and then
one of the other areas that i think is
one of the biggest levers today
which is fundamentally um
underserved and not understood is
the gender balance aspect i think right
yes
yeah yeah we have we have long neglected
um both within ourselves and across our
teams
the ability of human beings to be able
to expand their repertoire of
understanding and interpretation of the
world
to be able to encompass all aspects of
our capability for for for at the most
course level you know from a masculine
and feminine perspective from men and
women
but also into within the individuals
where we're able to expand our
repertoire of of uh
leadership traits and qualities and also
understanding
um and i think that as we see more women
enter into
the uh emerging tech space and als also
the innovation space we're beginning now
to identify
what are some of those leadership
capabilities that are unique and that we
want to cultivate and amplify
and then also what's the impact of those
in terms of being able to
increase innovation capability and
accelerate our innovation
ambitions right and actually you know
one thing that i just loved is you
corrected me right before we started
this show
because i was because when we started
talking about you know the females and
male leaders and then i was talking yes
diversity in tech is something that's
very common and he said well michael
it's not diversity it's 50 of the
population this is balanced
leadership and i just love that i'm
adopting that and i'm going to
be an advocate for that moving forward
what so what is it about now what what
is happening in this space today and
what do you think needs to happen
so that we have more balanced leadership
with with all the positives that come
with it
yeah yeah good um so i think it is about
balance
and and and not about diversity because
again it is half of the global
population a little bit more than half
actually which makes it even more
interesting
um but i think what's missing in here is
we've looked at this
um not as a business opportunity but as
a social justice
necessity and i think that is a huge
fallacy that undermined everything that
we're trying to do
so as business leaders some of the more
sophisticated advanced
for business leaders with tremendous
foresight
are recognizing um that there is a gold
mine of opportunity there
and if we can figure out how to leverage
that opportunity
that you know the leaders will obviously
win there the people who are the first
movers
um the difference that i have discovered
through the research that i've been
doing
um in in terms of wasted opportunity
is that we really don't have a way of
talking about what it is
that women are doing differently when
they lead and there's growing awareness
particularly with the pandemic
because we're seeing that the countries
that are led by women have done much
more successfully in the pandemic yes
yes right we're all asking ourselves why
and so i um decided about
about 20 years ago that i was really
interested in trying to understand what
women were doing differently
and how could you how could you name it
how could you identify it how could you
make it clear for other people so they
could understand it
and then how could you move that to
helping people value it
and expand their repertoire of
leadership and not just
women but women and men because some of
the more brilliant men that i've worked
for
have both male and female leadership
capabilities and their ability to
embrace those makes them better leaders
and so trying to understand not only how
that works for
us as individual human beings but how
that works across teams
and how we can take advantage of that is
is something that i've been focused on
for a while and how that
then impacts our innovation capability
so and does that also translate into
your work with how women invest as a
founding lp there and those sorts of
initiatives
yeah what's super interesting with how
women invest and i was talking to our
general partner the other day
and i said look there's a radical
difference between the
traditional venture capitalists who have
been venture capitalists
in pursuit of capital and distributing
you know
capital where they think they're going
to make higher returns and what how
women invest has built and what they've
done
is they have produced really i refer to
it now and and
and um there's growing awareness that
this is what it is
is we're venture catalysts
because what we're doing is we're taking
money and using it
to change opportunities for people and
not from a
um you know for benefits or social
justice perspective
we're taking the the entire um
venture capital space and saying um
how women invest has over 100 limited
partners
and what they're doing is that means
that there are 100 women who understand
the venture process who are there to
advise and support the startups
and who are having this catalytic effect
across the community that they're in the
middle of
which is 14 000 women across the world
and so the the the potential impact of
that
from a transformation standpoint is
really huge
so i'm super excited about the way my
brilliant general partners have designed
their fund
and the potential long-term impact it
can have across the community
that's incredible but jennifer i have to
now transition a little bit to you and
your passion because
how do you go from being a vice
president in wells fargo and the senior
director at cisco
and chief information officer and chief
information and security officer
at the stanford research institute and
you go from there to having this
surge of passion to to cultivate
innovation and understand better about
balanced leadership
what what what made that transition why
why are you doing that
so that wasn't it's not really a
transition because i've been doing that
my entire career
i've always um so i'm fundamentally
lazy and i always look for what's the
big lever
and so since the time i was younger than
you i went into business and i went i
need to find a big lever
i don't have to work as hard as these
crazy people around me so for me the
biggest lever was
how do you reframe ideas how do you
um change the way people think about
things and how do you bring people with
you because they want to come not
because you're telling them that that's
what they need to do
so um my focus has always been
on how do you um
how do you engage human beings
differently and
that to me is the biggest lever if we
don't understand how to be able to
mobilize
resources behind what we think is
important and find commonalities with
other humans
we're we're always having to do the
heavy lifting and so
i've used this approach um that i
learned my early 20s in
everything that i've done um and it's
allowed me to be able to build some
incredibly powerful teams because i'm
focusing on the emergent capabilities
and that was actually the name of one of
my companies
um and then i've also used it to be able
to go how do i help other people do that
so that they can build
more powerful teams around them to be
able to realize some of the dreams and
passions that they have
so give me one or two tips that i can
take for myself as i try to empower
others to want to join my team or want
to do things
for because they want to and not because
they have to because it sounds like
that's a key key aspect of innovation
and part of your success and all these
wonderful companies and corporations
that you worked on
yeah so i think um one of the things
there
is um the design element is
people tend to follow people who do
brilliant design
because people who do brilliant design
are looking to reduce the noise in the
system and increase
the signal and what it does is it
creates environments where
i as someone who would be on your team
can be more successful
just by virtue of the systems that you
build around you
um so one of the little adages i've been
using with some clients recently is an
hour of design
is is better than 10 hours of of
delivery
and so the people who build their design
capacity and design thinking is
obviously a fantastic tool for doing
that not just applied to product but
applied to everything that we do
is build your design capacity and then
recognize that what you're doing in the
middle of that design work
is you're providing frameworks and
constructs and opportunities for people
to be able to
learn and grow much more effectively
right and is there
is there some you know the feedback loop
that you're getting for people i'm
assuming that's a pretty big part of it
right
because it could be thinking that you're
that you're operating in a certain way
and that you're empowering people in a
certain way
a lot of this is relationship driven how
do you get that feedback from others
yeah so um one of the fantastic things
about the design thinking work
is and systems thinking is that you want
to be able to expose yourself to as many
feedback loops as possible
so when you're doing your design you're
looking to immerse yourself
not just in feedback that other human
beings will give you that's super
valuable but also in feedback that the
system itself will give you
so the focus on um uh customer focused
work the focus on customer design based
design work the focus on
interdisciplinary teams who are going to
provoke your thinking in different ways
and how do you really
create an immersive experience for
yourself and for your teams
in the biggest broadest ecosystem you
possibly can so that you're doing this
constant learning
and commit yourself to that and but do
it in a deliberate way
i think a lot of people might do
immersive
learning work but if you're not doing it
in a deliberate way where you're looking
to constantly improve your learning
capacity and build mastery over that
then you're missing out on a huge
opportunity so i'm i'm all about
deliberate practice 100 100 by the way
you mentioned earlier that
the part of your motivation for
developing these processes and
relationships is because you saw how
hard people were working and you were
trying to optimize a lot of things
and by and i i think that it's pretty
clear from this conversation that you're
working much harder than most people
that i know
so uh so thank you uh thank you for for
the inspiration behind both the
optimization but continuing to work so
hard
jennifer before we go i have to ask you
the most important question and the
hardest one
three words that you would use to
describe yourself and why why did you
choose those specific words
yeah so um i'm a co-inventor
i love doing things with other people i
love seeing
oh inventor i love that inventor yeah
it's what i
part of what i teach people to do so i
love being able to invent things with
other people and i love being able to
see
the brilliance and the beauty in other
people and bring that out
and and share with them and create
something bigger than both of us
um are than all of us so that's one of
one of my favorite things
to do um the other thing is i'm a
pragmatist and an executor because in
the end of the day there has to be value
for vast amounts of other human beings
otherwise
you know it's more effort than it's
worth and then the other thing that i do
the number of people have said to me
that i have never really thought of
myself as but now i'm beginning to
is i name ideas so i will see
people kind of grasping for something
that they want to make happen in the
world
and i work with them to define that to
distinguish that to translate that into
an offer
or a product or service or whatever it
is and really
name what that is not from a marketing
perspective but from a
development and deep understanding
perspective and and name ideas and help
them bring those ideas to
to reality so i that's i love it
jennifer thank you for the inspiration
thank you for being so generous with
your time i know how busy you are
and i can't wait to share this with the
world thank you thank you very much
pleasure michael
take care bye